[Music]  Serena Williams will soon welcome her  first child with fiance Alexis I'm  excited about it and the first time mom  is opening up about what she learned  from her own upbringing on Friday the  pregnant tennis champ spoke at a keynote  discussion during the blog her 17  conference about the best advice her mom  gave her about being a parent quote she  taught me about being so strong of being  proud of Who I am of being able to look  anyone in the face and have confidence  she added I really have been able to  embrace it and would love to teach my  kid that I've always tried to really be  myself and to defy that you know what  you're supposed to be like in what  you're supposed to act like as for  Serena's father  she says he taught her the value of  discipline I think that's definitely  true and it's clear from her slang at  tennis practice while pregnant  [Music]  you